Time travel is complicated.
After all, if it was simple and straightforward,
then everyone would do it.
Sure, on paper it sounds pretty easy to just
take a quick jaunt back to 1890, kill baby
Adolf and avert World War Two.
Millions of lives saved before lunch, and
surely the world would be all the better for
it, right?
But what if altering history didn’t change
the future - or the present as you knew it?
Perhaps instead, you unknowingly created a
new, alternate timeline, branching off from
the history you know into somewhere different?
Maybe in this new timeline, where you traveled
back in time and killed Hitler, someone even
worse rises to power and assumes control of
Germany before plunging the world into an
even deadlier war?
And even that is just one possible outcome
of your singular action, only fitting in with
one scientific theory of how the mechanics
of time travel might work, with no certainty
that it actually would happen like that.
Like we said, time travel is nowhere near
as easy as it seems in movies with flying
Deloreans and cyborg assassins who always
seem to keep coming back.
Keeping all that in mind, these big, perplexing
questions about time travel and alternate
timelines is the perfect segue into the focus
of today’s video.
Introducing SCP-1780, which is, brace yourselves...
A plastic name plate.
You know, the official, business-like kind
that you might find displayed on a desk in
a fancy office.
Wait, that’s it?
All that talk of world ending and the disruption
of multiple dimensional timelines is from
this thing?
You’re probably wondering what on infinite
earths this trivial piece of office stationery
could possibly have to do with the notion
of time travel, and we can tell you that the
connection will likely surprise you.
SCP-1780 itself appears pretty unassuming
at first, showing signs of aging and damage
from being buried for several decades.
The first interesting detail of note, however,
is that name plates of the exact same style
were used in the offices of the SCP Foundation
itself, from the year 1990 all the way up
to as recently as 2003.
SCP-1780 sports the Foundation’s emblem,
and the lettering on it is still legible despite
the wear and tear.
While the name is redacted, the rest of it
reads: “Ph.D / Chairperson: Temporal Anomalies
Department”.
Okay, so what could be so important about
a name plate?
Are the Foundation running so low on anomalies
that they have to lock up a harmless piece
of plastic from one of their very own offices?
Not quite.
You see, you have already missed the second,
most interesting detail about this particular
name plate.
Not only does the redacted name not match
any previous or existing staff member on their
database, but the SCP Foundation has never
even had a Temporal Anomalies Department.
Not in this timeline, anyway.
As for a “harmless name plate”, SCP-1780
is certainly anything but that.
Of course, the name plate itself does remain
inactive if left alone, but when it is placed
into a mount of appropriate size, then…
well, it’s not exactly easy to explain what
happens, but we’ll try our best, seeing
as we’re “SCP Explained”, after all.
Placing SCP-1780 into a name plate mount causes
a temporospatial anomaly to appear in the
nearest doorway.
This anomaly is known as SCP-1780-1, and according
to high speed photographs taken by the SCP
Foundation, it appears instantly, so fast
that its speed can hardly be measured.
Foundation researchers are flummoxed as to
exactly how this anomaly appears as well,
unable to quantify what it is made from or
what forms it.
What they do know is that whatever space was
originally behind the doorway now containing
SCP-1780-1 is now inaccessible through the
use of said door.
However, whichever room was once behind the
doorway can still be accessed by going around
the door, either by destroying the adjacent
walls or using another entrance.
The door that now contains SCP-1780-1 will
remain indestructible, and cannot be accessed
while the SCP-1780 name plate is activated.
So, SCP-1780-1, this temporospatial anomaly…
what exactly is it?
Once again, that is a question without an
easy answer.
The best way to describe it would be to imagine
it as a portal.
A portal leading where exactly?
Venturing through a doorway now hosting SCP-1780-1,
one will find themselves in an office.
In fact, this office is an exact match to
one found inside the Euclid Objects Experimentation
Wing of Site 17, one of the SCP Foundation’s
top secret containment facilities where they
store a number of dangerous anomalies.
The state of the SCP-1780-1 office varies
between visits, with signs of misuse, neglect
and general disrepair.
However, the interior of this office always
contains the same items.
Namely, there is standard office furniture,
the same type and style as those purchased
by the SCP Foundation during the renovation
of Site 17 in 1995.
There are also a number of whiteboards around
the office, all with text and complex mathematical
equations written on them.
The room also contains a loaded Remington
Model 870 shotgun, a copy of Oxford’s Unabridged
English Dictionary and three copies of Time
Life’s Great Ages of Man: A History of the
World’s Cultures, though strangely, only
one of these copies matches the history of
the world we know.
Finally, there is another name plate inside
the office, a second instance of SCP-1780,
complete with a name plate bracket to hold
it.
What does this all mean?
Is SCP-1780 capable of opening and closing
portals to just this single office?
And where or when is the SCP-1780-1 office?
Is it a pocket dimension?
A place in the future?
According to tests run by the SCP Foundation,
the multiple SCP-1780 name plates can be used
to create several simultaneous SCP-1780-1
portals.
Through the use of GPS tracking and other
redacted methods, the Foundation’s researchers
have been able to determine that, when there
are multiple instances of SCP-1780-1 doorways,
they will lead to the same office, in the
same physical space.
However, the different portals will be separated
by an unknown interval of time.
So, the leading theory is this: the office,
SCP-1780-1 is somehow temporally displaced.
It does not exist within its proper place
in the linear timeline, and could instead
be located somewhere outside time.
Anything left inside the office space, like
personal effects or even members of Foundation
personnel that get left behind, will vanish
if the portal is closed and reopened.
As long as the doorway remains open, SCP-1780-1
will behave in harmony with the normal flow
of time as we experience it.
But from the moment it closes, anyone left
inside the office is considered irretrievable.
But that isn't all.
Around one in every ten times that SCP-1780
is used to open the portal into the office,
SCP-1780-1 will contain something else.
Not just the items that usually appear in
the office, but people.
Well, that might be a bit of a stretch.
They are humanoids, at least, shaped like
people.
Referred to as SCP-1780-2, these entities
vary dramatically in their appearance and
behavior.
There is, nevertheless, one consistency to
them: they will all always claim to be personnel
working for the SCP Foundation.
Some of the SCP-1780-2 have alleged themselves
to be Site 17 security staff, assigned to
guard SCP-1780.
These entities are usually passive and cooperative
when existing Foundation security interacts
with them.
Others have made the assertion that they are
field agents or researchers assigned to an
unknown project.
According to them, this project is focused
on dealing with temporal anomalies.
These SCP-1780-2s tend to behave drastically
differently, and are often far more unpredictable.
In some cases, they have even been hostile
towards Foundation personnel, and have even
self-terminated when efforts have been made
to contain them.
The third and final type of SCP-1780-2 entity
seems to be singularly unique, even with its
own designation: SCP-1780-2a.
This entity refers to itself by the name Doctor
Thaddeus Xyank, and when questioned by the
Foundation, will refuse to give any information
at all.
A number of times, personnel have asked this
Doctor Xyank about his origins, the goals
of his research, even where or when he came
from, and every time, he hasn’t told them
anything of use.
SCP-1780-2a cannot be captured either, and
seems to have an in-depth firsthand knowledge
of the Foundation.
He is able to predict all their containment
tactics for hostile humanoids, and has used
this foresight to evade any attempt to capture
him for further questioning.
Right now, there are probably a million questions
popping into your head.
Is the SCP-1780-1 office part of a branching
timeline?
Are the entities within Foundation agents
from an alternate history, trapped and displaced
in time?
Well, some of the answers we may never know.
But some might be found in SCP-1780-3, the
name given to a document that has often also
been found within the SCP-1780-1 office space.
Much like the rest of the furniture and stationery
inside SCP-1780-1, this document seems to
be from the SCP Foundation itself, printed
on their letterhead from around 1998.
The author of this document appears to have
been SCP-1780-2a, Doctor Thaddeus Xyank himself.
Somehow, either as an intentional booby trap
or as some sort of side effect from the temporal
displacement of the office, SCP-1780-3 has
anomalous properties on the reverse side of
the paper.
After being accidentally exposed to this effect,
a Foundation agent disappeared and was presumed
dead, only to reappear within the office space
fourteen years later as an instance of SCP-1780-2,
appearing to have not physically changed one
bit in all that time.
As for the contents of the SCP-1780-3 document?
It appears to be an introductory letter and
orientation materials composed by Doctor Thaddeus
Xyank and intended for the special project
team investigating temporal anomalies.
Anyone that reads the full document has suffered
the same fate as that other agent, disappearing
through unknown means.
However, the Foundation has kept a hard copy
of the document in storage, with the reverse
obscured to prevent its anomalous effect.
An excerpt of Doctor Xyank’s letter is also
kept on file, available to read to those who
hold adequate security clearance.
In this letter, Doctor Xyank explains that
there are, in fact, multiple different timelines.
According to him, of all the timelines to
exist, many have their own version of the
SCP Foundation or another similar organization.
But, only a few of these other alternate Foundations
have a specific department dedicated to studying
time based anomalies.
That is why there is no Temporal Anomalies
Department in the SCP Foundation as we know
it.
It could be possible that Doctor Thaddeus
Xyank and all the other SCP-1780-2s are staff
from a different version of the Foundation,
that exists on a different timeline.
The letter continues, as Doctor Xyank claims
that “everything you know about temporal
dynamics is fundamentally flawed.
Despite what even I might tell you, Paradoxes
Do Exist.
Loosely defined, a temporal paradox is any
situation arising from an interruption in
an ordered sequence of events which requires
that two contradictory outcomes be held as
true by the universe simultaneously.”
That sounds awfully verbose and complicated,
but what he means is, a time paradox occurs
when something disrupts the flow of a timeline.
This then effectively splits the timeline
into two streams, creating a pair of similar,
yet slightly different timelines that continue
to flow parallel with each other.
You see, we experience time as a single path,
a straight line.
Now, imagine that path in front of you had
multiple other paths branching off of it.
Whichever way you choose to walk, a different
choice means you might’ve ended up walking
on another branching path that is similar,
but will always be separate, distinct, and
different.
Doctor Xyank then goes on to outline the mission
statement of his Temporal Anomalies Department.
Their goal is, in essence, to safeguard and
protect these various timelines.
They hope to ensure that the events that led
to the existence of their department, their
version of the SCP Foundation and even humanity
as a whole, must always happen as recorded
by history.
From a base of operations that is temporally
isolated, existing outside time, Doctor Xyank
and the Temporal Anomalies Department intend
to keep the history of human civilization
consistent and prevent any and all possible
future threats that might bring about the
end of the world as we know it.
So, there we have it, SCP-1780.
An unassuming name plate that opens a portal
to an office outside of time itself.
An office belonging to a Foundation department
that doesn’t exist in this timeline, but
whose mission is to protect ours and every
other branching path of possibilities.
Like we said before, time travel: it’s pretty
complicated.
Now go check out “SCP-5000 Why?
- The Full Story Compilation” and “SCP-5545
- Mysterious Tunnels in Antarctica - ABNORMALITY”
for more mind-bending anomalies from the SCP
Foundation!